estou muito feliz pelo convite eu sempre
gosta de vir ao rio de janeiro
mais tarde que me encanta muito falar
sobre o tema educação então nem se fala
porque para a minha corrente sanguínea
desde os 14 anos de idade é e cada vez
mais aflorado esse tema na minha vida
é difícil você falar um evento como esse
do tédio depois de caras brilhantes como
edu como dinho que o respeito que eu
convivo que eu sempre procuro conversar
com eles na verdade é muito mais que
falar de casos eu quis trazer aqui uma
pincelada de várias provocações para
deixar sementes na cabeça de vocês sobre
os desafios sobre os dilemas que a gente
tem educação
esse título de morte e vida da educação
inspirado num livro de jacobs que fala
sobre a morte e vida das grandes cidades
se você quiser entender sobre redes
sociais
comece por essa leitura porque redes
sociais não é o facebook não é o twitter
não é nenhuma dessas plataformas e redes
sociais são pessoas interagindo com
pessoas e adm jacobs descobriu o rap
hour o poder das calçadas nas grandes
cidades
quando a gente fala de educação três
imagens que vem na cabeça de vocês logo
de cara quando a gente ouve essa palavra
olha só que curioso escola professor
ensino
eu vou mostrar uma seqüência de imagens
aqui e qualquer semelhança é pura
coincidência tá mas vejam só que curioso
uma sala de aula da década de 30 a 40
sala de aula de hoje uma escola rural
uma escola na coreia os melhores
indicadores
educacionais do planeta mesmo ensino de
arte uma escola rural na áfrica
percebam que o aluno para aprender ele
tem que olhar na nuca do outro aluno o
professor ao centro do conhecimento
eu tenho ouvido muito falar nos últimos
tempos sobre a tecnologia na educação e
tecnologia vai revolucionar a educação
vai salvar o problema da educação será
vamos ver
olha só como é tratada a tecnologia da
sala de aula
continuamos aprendendo olhando na nuca
do outro aluno e professor centro de
conhecimento ou seja grande e sábio
dilma já dizia que os espaços
padronizados produziram idéias
padronizadas
quem aqui de vocês e me responda com
sinceridade nunca usou o sms na sala de
aula nunca disparou essa imensa sala de
aula levando o braço não será a
tecnologia se digitalizou tudo aquilo
que a gente já faz eu já fazia muito
tempo e olha só que maluquice é essa
dentro de uma sala de aula com o celular
estamos presos a grade curricular já
começa errado por aí na grade prisão ou
a sociedade da decoreba que a gente vem
inclusive pais criticando os filhos
porque não sabem de cor e salteado as 27
capitais brasileiras
mas ele sabe que ele foi no google
criaria as 27 capitais ea gente cada vez
mais preso aos padrões globais de
indicadores que medem língua portuguesa
e matemática mas que abomina a ciência
que a bobina o ensino das artes o lado
direito do cérebro a esteem à escola
quase matou porque ele era o alunos
atento
disléxico
e aí o que que é então o tal do
conhecimento que a gente tá falando o
conhecimento sempre viveu espalhado pelo
mundo mas determinadas dos séculos o
homem achou que deveria trancar isso em
algum lugar e se aprisionar esse
conhecimento sistematizado esse
conhecimento é que surgem os livros e
argentina é metido a besta que a maior
biblioteca do mundo aprisionando todos
os livros conhecimento não é algo que
você embute na cabeça de uma pessoa numa
objeto que você vai lá na prateleira do
supermercado recolhe 500 gramas de
álgebra 200 gramas de sócrates mas é uma
relação social é pela observação que a
gente consegue aprender a gente vai
aprender ela pra mim aprendi a viver
vivendo o que a gente está fazendo e
vive aprendendo o tempo inteiro a partir
dessas nossas reflexões todo fazer então
ele é um conhecer ele é um aprendizado
larga teoria o pé no chão arregaça as
mangas
olha só que barato e se mantém em
cingapura em si - e aprenda mais qual
nosso mantra enquanto nação na educação
a gente perdeu e aí a gente quer sempre
privar a criança da sua criatividade
ora coisa maluca uma criança hoje seis
anos de idade na escola privada
ela tem aula de filosofia faz prova
bimestral respondendo pra ela que a
raiva e você olha a grade curricular
só tem um monte de matérias disciplinas
e você começa já na cadeia aqui brincar
cada espaço de socialização dessa
criança
óbvio que o formato
- que a gente está fazendo a gente
produzindo ea internet está tentando
entender né que a internet precisa com
essa moçada e tudo mais e as crianças
cada vez mais procuram coisas dentro da
internet
desenvolve o raciocínio e é um
raciocínio que a geração mais velha não
consegue compreender é uma outra lógica
a gente vê os críticos falando a essa
moça tinha agora não sabe escrever que
escreve vc lugar de você
se você estudar a história de qualquer
linguagem no planeta ela tem um período
de evolução de mudança será que está
acontecendo esse movimento agora mas o
que de fato a gente precisa exercer mais
com os nossos alunos é criticidade a
perguntar por que colocar interrogações
o aprendizado não ocorre só naquela fase
escolar ou naquela fase universitária é
para toda a vida
cada vez mais as pessoas estão se dando
conta disso hoje muito do que a gente
ouviu aqui para pôr esta manhã
certamente só 15 minutos a gente
conseguiu gravar na universidade na
escola então nem se fala só que se você
tivesse dado uma disciplina técnica da
universidade saiba que no final do
quarto ano quando você terminar e se
formar em um terço daquele conteúdo tá
fresco na sua cabeça a usável na sua
vida
o professor de sair do palco um pouco
mais sair do centro das atenções
abandonar o sistema mais massivo de
educação falou isso também foi professor
universitário e não é uma mudança só dos
professores que fica o alerta
a mudança na educação é dos alunos
também porque certa vez eu fui renovar
um processo na sala de aula a segunda
aula me perguntar o professor quando é
que vai da matéria e tocar com canetinha
flip chart
o aluno também está aberto para esta
inovação que os professores possam
imprimir dentro da sala de aula porque
eles vão estimular a eles devem
estimular o processo de descoberta é a
minha crítica sobre os padrões globais
de ensino focarem na área matemática na
língua portuguesa enquanto que a ciência
tem uma das maiores competências uma das
maiores habilidades que ela pode nos
ensinar que o prazer da descoberta
ao invés de a gente ficar decorando
coisas a educação de massiva está em um
grande dilema para nossa sociedade como
tornar o ensino a educação aprendizagem
individualizada
agora dá para pensar que os filhos hoje
educam os pais
está claro para todo mundo porque os
filhos crescem mais tecnologia e ensina
os pais quando é que se mexe no
computador
como é que se mexe no celular o diretor
da da xerox parc primeiro centro de
inovação tecnológica dessa nova
tecnologia do conhecimento fala que
antes os pais era uma grande figura da
autoridade hoje não tem tanta autoridade
assim liberdade limite em 35 anos
eu vi o rescaldo do processo da ditadura
a fase das diretas ainda criança
mal sei o que foi aquilo que um jovem
conheceu um processo como esse no brasil
a gente na fundação telefônica fez
diversas chamadas com jovens que teve
que mudar a pergunta eu não sei
o que é ter limite
inovação eu queria trazer aqui o
iluminismo como uma grande inspiração o
que caras como a 2001 joseph priestley
tinham em comum neste período todo
iluminismo tantas outras figuras
os cafés em londres eles se encontravam
nos cafés e conversavam
era lá que ocorria a interação
era lá que ocorria a polinização cruzada
de idéias
olha eu descobri um evento tá aqui a
minha receita no papel de pão totó leva
o código fique à vontade pra mexer faz o
que quiser mas depois não esquece de
compartilhar comigo que você fez de
mudança só vou saber onde foi que eu
errei
naquela época direito autoral
hoje tem creative commons com uma grande
bandeira já que o ser humano também tem
um lado sombrio da força
mas afinal qual é a conexão do
iluminismo com os dias de hoje
olha só que coisa maluca está
acontecendo em muitas empresas
a gente está descobrindo os cafés
a gente está fazendo muita inovação e
nos cafés é hoje café é design thinking
uma série de abordagens ou metodologias
aplicadas em todos esses espaços
mas o maior valor já está redescobrindo
é que o café é o espaço da conversa ao
espaço da troca
e quando a gente ouve falar a palavra
inovação também como é que a inovar é
que tipo de inovação você está buscando
sendo que você tranca corpos num
laboratório
e o pior é você tem de segunda a sexta
feira das 8 às cinco da tarde para
entregar uma inovação oi assim esse
bando de metodologias que um monte de
gente está aplicando está redescobrindo
está criando para inovar mas a gente não
precisa só de ambiente
as pessoas também precisam
esta combinação que causa essa grande
inovação é isso que vai provocar a
inovação no centro universitário na
escola pública na escola privada
falando de futuro a gente vai
construindo mundo ao mesmo tempo ele vai
nos construindo você é o que você
compartilha a cair já que vão emitir um
grande pensador da pedagogia alguém aqui
faz o curso de pedagogia ou algo similar
e valente nem é visto mais as cadeiras e
pedagogia
ele fala da busca e da polinização
como é que a gente trabalha com os
nossos jovens para faça as perguntas
certas para o google e toquem com os
colegas desperta neles o prazer pela
curiosidade pela criatividade numa área
de onde o autodidatismo é cada vez mais
aflorado na internet hoje 23 buscas
você aprendeu como fazer cerveja em casa
ou do autodidatismo que a gente sempre
praticou quem é que nunca aperfeiçoou
uma receita da avó porque aprendeu com a
mãe e depois ensinou a mãe a sabedoria
hoje cada vez mais ao estarmos nas
multidões está ficando mais claro para a
gente tudo isso e não é num prédio na
estrutura física que está a sabedoria
a gente está vivendo uma era onde está
buscando o autoconhecimento coletiva se
entender como sociedade ac ad school of
life
nascido em londres e está provocando
isso essa reflexão para todos nós
olha só que coisa maluca que esse é um
modelo de negócio nas em curitiba
a escola das coisas que não se aprendem
na escola não sabe você sabe trocar um
chuveiro você pode dar aula na escola
sabe vocês a pintar a parede pode dar um
curso
a quest online nos estados unidos onde
as crianças aprendem através dos games e
é isso que é tornar mais divertido
aprendizado ou indiano sugata mitra que
fez um experimento de um buraco na
parede a gente trouxe para o brasil a
periferia de são paulo ele aplicou a
metodologia as crianças sozinhas
aprender o inglês em três meses em
lândia na suécia os designers cada vez
mais repensando os espaços o design dos
espaços educativos ou muitos jovens
abandonando as nossas universidades
nossas escolas criando seus próprios
manifestos
para eles o que aprender
as universidades o emite impulsionando a
abertura de cursos livres ou criando
consórcio com diversas universidades e
não é e não é raiva de não é emitido
nessa plataforma
são todos juntos a unicamp entre outras
universidades estão juntos o cam na
academia onde você pode aprender
matemática e agora linguagem de
programação através da internet com um
vídeo aulas
o próprio rei da copérdia os professores
ou uma metodologia chamada ser virologia
você tem as perguntas que provocam você
tem um celular na mão computador na sua
mão um amigo se vira vai atrás
como diz sérgio vaz ocorre cada vez mais
as empresas disponibilizando leve morte
a que mais de um milhão de pessoas
aprendem idiomas qualquer idioma pelo
mundo não é com professores nenhuma
escola ou você pode gravar um trecho da
sua música ou um trechinho de música uma
guitarra e deixar na web qualquer um
pode usar ou você pode conhecer
tratamentos médicos e questionar o seu
médico que aquele é o tratamento mais
adequado para você como está ocorrendo
nos estados unidos
ou então como eu falei da escola das
coisas que você não aprende na escola
você não pode usar uma plataforma e
agendar uma aula do que você souber de
melhor ganhar dinheiro com isso em
qualquer espaço da cidade
você pode promover festivais de idéias
ainda sair com dinheiro semente está a
colocar em prática seu projeto a sua
ideia ou pertence a uma rede de leitores
e aqui uma pergunta na universidade
qual o futuro dos cursos técnicos até aí
esse curso têm dia e hora para morrer
por que um alto com 13 anos já criou 15
aplicativos do iphone
ora isso é genial ainda usa o wifi da
starbucks uma sociedade que está
fechando direito autoral e propriedade
intelectual
onde nós todos trabalhamos gratuitamente
pelo google onde 100 milhões de horas e
ditando o equipe dia gratuitamente onde
até macumba online você faz aprender
tricô e crochê
o que vale a gente é que cada vez mais o
poder das escolhas está na mão de cada
indivíduo não mais alguém de fora que
determina sua escolha o que motiva você
é ver com o que é que te recompensa
nós somos seres cooperativas que nós
temos propósitos comuns e aí está uma
chave para uma virada
quais são as bandeiras que a gente quer
inspirar o nosso jovem a nossa
comunidade as causas cada vez mais são
relevantes cada pessoa é uma diversidade
de causas bastante previstas
manifestações cada vez mais os novos
modelos de aprendizagem emergindo
ou seja o objetivo da educação não é
ensinar importa cada vez mais não é o
que você sabe que você pode aprender não
é o da coleção de diplomas que você tem
na parede
você não tem que ter o anseio de forçar
que alguém tem que aprender aquilo na
marra mas sim despertar nele o prazer
pela descoberta dentro dele mesmo e essa
pra mim é uma grande chave na última
provocação
eu guardo o meu conhecimento
eu sempre dizia que meus alunos de
marketing
acabou esse curso que vai fazer um curso
de mecânica a fazer um curso de vinho
porque a rede que você vai estabelecer
de contatos é que vai te dar maior poder
de conhecimento não é você tem dentro do
seu cérebro armazenado
obrigado